astrophysicist and straight-up genius
neil degrasse tyson
um
neil
has anyone here seen the movie don't
look up yes
great that is so helpful to this quick
conversation because i had to sidebar i
know you tweeted about don't look up so
when i saw don't look up i watched it at
night before bed alone
big mistake
you should watch it with friends during
the daytime yeah um but the next day the
movie really resonated with me
and i had a very different feeling about
it kind of in processing it
what do you think of the film you were
tweeting about it give me the yeah i you
know i saw it like everybody else
and you know it's comical and playful
and thing and then i said
wait a minute
that's the experience i had on social
media that's my experience i had with
with the news and with politicians and i
started assembling the puzzle pieces and
i said to myself
this isn't just some story
this is a documentary
of what
would happen if we find a killer
asteroid i don't know that i have
confidence that we have the collective
societal maturity
to
handle that information
and to save
civilization that we have so long hard
built
as part of what it is to be alive in
this world as human beings so yeah i
scared me to death too
oh yeah yeah and i'll tell you just just
i mean think of the global warming
analog to that right yes almost every
important city in the world was built on
the water's edge be it a lake a river or
the ocean to enable commerce
transportation irrigation do you realize
if we lose the green wind and antarctic
ice caps the water levels will rise to
the stature of liberty's left elbow
flooding every city that we spent
centuries building i mean how selfish
can you be to say oh my descendants
they'll have to deal with it but right
now i'm going to maximize every thread
of profit i can
so
i i'd look at the beautiful civilization
that we have crafted i don't want to
lose it i agree and in fact your
beautiful book which is your eighteenth
i thought i'd watched i wasn't
[Applause]
it's like it has goggles in it that
enable you to see pairs of images as
full 3d but the value of it is well like
there's the moon in there
where it's not just a picture of the
moon
the moon pops and it becomes a world
right in front of your eyes and it's the
it's the world building that this
how freaking cool is this you guys
no book comes with this neil i love you
so much
it's hard to produce a book like this no
it's not easy right right so it takes
you from the small out to the large and
you see the universe and you also see
the constellations thinking that they're
just patterns on a night sky but they
pop into the full three dimensions that
they are and this you see the stars
scattered through space and you say wait
a minute i thought those are supposed to
influence me because it was a lion or a
centaur or or a crab i do love a centaur
they're so cool
and neil yeah so that's a whole other
access point oh one other thing can i
say this please that each of those
pictures has has a caption so if you go
to the website
welcome to the universe.net
there's you see the whole series of
books that this is a part of but in
there there's there's a bonus feature
where i narrate each of those captions
while you're looking through this and so
and i use my planetarium voice
which is
welcome to the universe
neil as a last question yeah if uh
speaking of men trying to colonize um
because i i don't know if it's a you
know i don't know what's up with that
same thing a testosterone thing yeah i
don't know what it is but if jeff bezos
elon musk or richard branson called you
to go
on the next flight would you go so
here's what i would do with um uh so
elon is the only one actually putting
people into orbit
that would be kind of fun so i say elon
put me in orbit and between bezos and
branson i'd party with richard branson
you have been here party with branson
and orbit with elon orbit with elon and
ask bezos i just go can i get my package
tomorrow afternoon at three o'clock how
did you change the world
oh neil you are the greatest don't
forget to get your amazing
unusual changes yeah very unusual it's
very unique an extraordinary book
welcome to the universe in 3d a visual
tour because it's in stores right now
neil please may i never have to spend an
earth day without you that is a
beautiful request which i will honor
[Music]
you